One explanation for missing data is that something maybe
failing occasionally when collecting your data. For example, if
you were conducting a traditional door to door survey,
maybe the person handling the documents looses a few, or
tends to miss some streets at random because they
don't know the geography of your town very well.
This is a case of a researcher or collection
technique causing missing data. The offline example of someone conducting
a traditional door-to-door survey can easily be translated to
the digital world. Imagine your data collection software fails one
out of every 1,000 times, or you have a
couple of service outages. You could have similar data loss.
If this were to happen in our baseball player
data set, we might see some missing values here and
there, just because we made some error in collecting
them at random. Another more harmful reason values may be
missing is referred to as non response. In
the case of non response, a certain subset of
people chooses not to answer particular questions. Or
don't respond at all. This can lead to biases
in your data and consequently, false conclusions. In
the case of baseball data, say we were interested
in the batting average of players. Maybe, since
they're, I don't know, self-conscious about their batting average.
All outfielders just don't provide a value. This would
make our results inaccurate and lead us to conclude
that the average batting average was 312 even though
that is based only one data point here, Derek Jeter's.
The important point here is this, if the missing
values from your data are distributed at random. Your
data may still be representative of the population. However,
if values are missing systematically, it could invalidate your findings.
It's important to design your experiment or
data collection method to minimize these effects. Beyond
this, it's very important to check your data to see if such effects are present.